welcome to this video playing hanging
pawns from the US yeah let's do
something else what about what about the
Mullen benoni I risky opening risky
business but what is it no risk no fun
yeah I didn't upload the game before
that a game that I lost but this was
against someone who's some I think very
clearly cheating and well sometimes I do
upload those videos because they are
sometimes interesting I like why are
they cheating how are they cheating
whatever but I didn't didn't really see
the point this this time I mean saying
if you if you're playing and someone
where you know beforehand that they
cheat you really you even play worse
yeah it is just because you're so
irritated by the fact that you're
playing against the machine well anyway
I hope he gets gets banned soon ok ok we
have a fee on Chet open only in recent
times there are more cheetahs around i
really don't know why that is but some
somewhat strange i mean i don't get the
point anyway but it kind of it seems to
be since so do to get worse so somehow
ok so i probably have lost some time
here with what 95 but well it happens
here if you if you are not an expert on
this opening which i'm definitely not i
know that there is this kind of idea but
well he has gotten all this activity
array Oh Bishop g7 this maybe five
coming up
now okay I cannot spend all day here I'm
kind of mixing systems yeah probably not
in a good way takes and then be five now
probably did you get some activity going
here yeah night takes he will probably
just take a Sno Tek say six he cannot
you cannot take on a six yeah maybe 26
rugae it so maybe this is the most
active move then I thought c4 and then
97 to c5 I mean it's the way you plated
with f4 is it's obviously very
aggressive but it also it also has left
some weaknesses behind so let's try that
okay um yeah I want to go to see five of
us not see five but he will probably
take it then play a five yeah I can try
to prepare it Queen here and then Queen
95 yes bishop okay Bishop before I might
take em play Quincy five this could be
okay check
I have asked some counter play against
the beep on so now this might be of this
might be okay actually let's see how do
I do that Knight to d7 and then look
before and look before p 8 yeah lamb
that symbol it sets okay it could be
really okay also Knight f6 maybe at the
right moment attacking the e4 pawn okay
first I'm covering here if I was hanging
maybe I should have just taken you for
him yeah but he did the problem persists
it still hangs right okay so are on or
Knight f6 Knight f6 out if he moves the
how does it protect the pond look you
wanna take me too yep is ditching one of
his pawns okay I can go back here though
cover the night
f05 ok so is in for Knight to g5
probably but I have rook be fire and
then sits on an ok answer i can t i can
take first 95 well let's just pile up on
this pawn i can still take it on ok you
will get you will get a six ok ok six
maybe maybe you look be 6 i'm not sure
b6 ok we can get this end game at least
the depot nesa is gone which is which is
helpful in any case and the pawn
structure is of course very favorable
let's see how do i do that the night to
night 21 f 5 would be excellent some
somehow let's start with that it's also
dominating its night a little bit it's
not so easy for for whites to play
Knight h5 is also most
just don't do this yarn it4s but its
dominating his his piece just a bit too
slow here is seven this may be good but
then I can go to the 60m where I want
where I want to be it's a funny funny
little trap young rookie 796 okay once
you go there anyway yeah yeah I was
thinking of a trap with them with the
fork it's always always in the mix yeah
the four kings for ideas now looked it
to a threatened time morning can't see
hmm no that's that's not great actually
time is usage and cami this is leading
to Luke and game with two points up but
it's too f pawns that the advantages in
terms of practical play that is
relatively easy for me to play it's
probably a draw I can claim any quick
moves
but even so sure if it's a draw check
check now that looks it starts to look
very very promising actually even H pawn
is a draw but this is kind of lot lots
of pawns check
check check check check I'm not sure
exactly check why don't we get 30 just
said that stumbled into rock f3 yeah
okay time when with free porns upper
thing is okay yeah so how did that this
happen we had a modern benoni yeah I
don't really know him this is oof I
think it looks kind of normal but maybe
that's not right that I'm not only not
sure if well f-for looks ya did it sends
my pieces back but it also yeah weakens
wide a little bit this is kind of
exposed with FYI deform yeah now it gets
interesting he plays a 5 yeah it looks
normal of course but he could have also
gone for something more conservative and
look like that for example then I
sometimes black has this idea that's
important to know yeah form for this
fork but here white is probably able to
take and play you five which looks kind
of depressing okay a5 went back yeah I
know I took this chance yeah of course
structurally i'm a bit weak but i'm
getting getting some activity here 495
be sure here here yeah and maybe
somewhere here i don't think that Bishop
de force leading to that much the comp
is giving rook a five
this is indeed looking like a strong
move because now I move like this can be
answered by the capture and d5 if he
gets in this sin center with my bishop
on g7 it's very imposing and here
catalysis all of a sudden giving me a
good gamer because now the remaining
pieces they work together pretty nicely
and I have the two targets that that I'm
attacking um amor are more accessible
than his targets on a six and ce4 yeah
and no no something's going to drop yeah
i was actually unsure here yeah this is
a very good end game that's a really
very good night f6 the thing is it's a
pawn and he just got the it's got the
word structure that on top is so is
quite quite much yeah probably maybe
this is stronger that yeah that is
stronger here this is important after
this and I have rookie foil both
discovered checks are not doing much and
now I'm threatening Knight f3 and the
capture ok so this what I was just going
here because of the practical side
because now I can play quick moves and I
actually can one on time at the end with
pre moves I'm just quicker ok well
thanks for watching